uh my wife elizabeth page henry hi
hey what do you do stan i'm an fbi agent
this scene is very realistic
hello uh my name is jack barski i
uh spied on behalf of the kgb for 10
years 1978 to 1988 and
in 2014 i became a u.s citizen
today i'm going to play a movie critic
based on my experience my actual
experience an espionage
this is something that could have
happened in real life how you
clear a dead drop those kinds of false
coins existed
the way he then opens the coin by using
tools that are readily available and
the fact that there was a little piece
of paper with some information on it
it's quite realistic because you know i
i got bits and pieces of information
uh through shortwave radio and i
transmitted
information in a film cartridge
where i photographed stuff that i wrote
down on on paper
i would occasionally wander around in a
park and uh
oh boy here's an oil can it was a
crushed coil can i
uh i take that take it home and then
use some pliers and screwdrivers to open
this thing up
and voila there was a passport and money
in there
i know the story quite well abel was
considered the hero
in the kgb while i wasn't training i
don't know if he was still alive when i
was in moscow
it has been documented from both sides
with a lot of exaggeration
both the americans and the soviets
played up his worth
what he actually did and what he
accomplished what happens in situations
like that
you can you can use
agents once they're caught for
propaganda services
i doubt that the fbi stormed
his apartment the way that they did that
looks unprofessional
why are you running what you do you if
you want to start somebody's apartment
you wait until they're out and then they
do that in secret that's the way my
house was
searched while i was on vacation the fbi
made a mistake
once they're in there to allow able to
touch anything
i would give it probably an aid does
this service to
the professionalism of the fbi
everything else is really
very realistic your profile interests us
you have talents and skills that we can
help you develop
you're offering me a job i'm offering
you a fresh start
one year's military training four years
operational in the field
the recruitment and training of people
who who
would do things like you know go to
another country and
do bad things to good people i only know
about this from
uh you know second-hand reports the kdb
had a very very murderous history
particularly in the beginning after
stalin died
they became a little more civilized but
they were still doing
bad things my recruitment was completely
different
it was it was a very very soft approach
and it took a long time for
about almost two years to finally ask me
if i if i
was willing and ready to join them
i was um third year students at universe
a student at university
when somebody introduced themselves his
cover was at the time he said
you know i'm a representative from a
local uh
business and he wanted to just know
because he
told me we know that you're a good
student what are your plan
plans after you graduate from college in
those days
in east germany you were assigned after
you to a post
once you graduated from college at that
point when he said that i
i thought he was the stasi east german
secret police
to me it was a great honor because you
know in those days the soviet union was
uh strength-wise at least the way we
perceived it
the equal to the united states and the
kgb
probably was the most powerful secret
service in the entire world
i would still think uh is highly
unrealistic
uh i would i would give that a zero hey
phil jennings how you doing stan beeman
uh my wife elizabeth page henry
hi what do you do stan i'm an fbi agent
this scene is very realistic there were
10 of us
we were supposed to live a life of
ordinary americans
now how the two kids fit into there that
you know especially already at that age
there were some
agents that had children uh
i know a friend of mine who was an
undercover agent
for the kgb and at the same time i was
there and he was there with his wife
actually they had a kid who was born in
brooklyn
my own experience was a little bit
different than that the fbi
when they started investigating me they
managed to buy the house next door
agents
occupied this house for a number of
months to
just watch me but they never really did
introduce themselves
uh they this was just for purposes of
observation
which when i became a public persona
the producers of the americans were like
really giddy
in that you know it was like it appeared
that life was
imitating art in that respect spies are
people too
you do form relationships that wasn't
even
a hint of something like that ever being
considered
nothing you get nothing from us
she's trained for this so am i we'll die
before we'll talk
we know how to do that the americans are
quite civilized
this is a quote i remember one of the
guys told me uh
they will not torture you the worst
thing
they might do to you is slap you on the
face a couple of times
all right so therefore this this scene
is uh is unrealistic
from both ends this is not how u.s
counter intelligence operates
and this is not how a trained agent
would respond
that's over the top insane the way these
two agents supposedly operated
uh running a travel agency full-time
being full-time parents and then doing
all kinds of uh uh being involved in all
kinds of operations that require
a lot of work a lot of preparation that
will require you to be in three
different places at the same time
all of this is totally unrealistic i
told them every time i see one of those
main characters running around with a
wig i wince
because that's the last thing that you
want to do because god forbid
somebody spots you and says wait a
minute i know this guy
he looks different what that that's a
hard
the wigs i mean that's a total no-no
with one exception the people that work
uh surveillance uh they
sometimes change the way they they dress
they change a jacket or
they put a scarf on but that's not
ever recommended for somebody who was
supposed to be a long-term
operational undercover agent on content
i would give the americans a 5.
training is useful but there is no
substitute for experience i agree
we use life targets as well
this was very entertaining i mean i
laughed
uh particularly at the sentence we use
live
targets this whole training set up even
from a
fictional aspect it doesn't make any
sense the kgb clearly had bad guys
but this this this fellow with a leather
jacket
i never met some kgb officer with a
leather jacket
if you met them today the way they were
then you would think they're just normal
everyday people that's the whole point
of being a spy
you you don't want to look like one this
guy looks like a commissar
based on the the way they were dressed
in during the
revolutionary times in russia the kgb
was
too compartmentalized you know i met
nothing but
gentlemen gentlemen who operated
uh on behalf of the soviet union for a
cause
and we were all committed communists but
uh
if we if we had if they had tried to
make a military unit out of the folks
that i worked with
we would we would have lost in the first
battle
all of a sudden she has a weapon in her
shoe
there's a kgb museum in new york city
and and they have
some real gadgets that were used by the
kgb
they would be given to most likely
only only a very special people
who were executing a particular very
special assignment
just like go out and kill somebody or
poison somebody
but this was not standard
equipment any of these gadgets are
evidence if counter intelligence goes
through your home and they find
even one thing with a secret compartment
i was operating within
the universe of what's normal
and you can find a whole lot of things
that you can use for
tools and toys uh that that you can buy
in any store
it's a minus one rule number one never
take your eye off your opponent my god
yeah i like i like the acting it's
interesting
my training in self-defense was
significantly
less aggressive i learned a handful of
moves
i did get some self-defense training
uh not to attack uh
fbi or uh you know counterintelligence
but to defend myself in case i wind up
uh at one point in a in a dangerous
neighborhood
with some stuff on me like money or
compromising materials that's all the
weapons
training i got this is killer training
here what we're looking at
kgb contingent was called spesnats the
special forces
like the marines they were trained for
these special type of operations we
jumping ahead of ourselves to think that
anything that's out in the media
in in movies and podcasts and whatever
uh will get really close to the absolute
truth
well even the five it's well filmed it's
uh these are first-rate actors
the name of the russian agent is salt
heavenly salt my name is evelyn salt
then you are a russian spy
truthful so far the fmri scan registers
truthful
on everything he said
this is pure fiction on a number of
levels
first of all sleepers were completely
isolated
in other words i couldn't betray anybody
even if i wanted to the russians did
did this very well uh what we call this
compartmentalization
there's no such thing as a brain scan
that will help you discover the truth
i was still subjected to a lie detector
test
which is the fbi still likes a lot
but it's it can be defeated you have to
really really believe in the lie and be
a congenital liar
double agents existed it and uh there
was
uh a couple of cases where the kgb had a
mole within the
fb fbi and within the cia who did a lot
of damage
if i may i give it a double zero are you
working for the americans
i love my country
this is uh taking kgb
practices of the 30s
40s into the early 50s and moving them
forward into sort of
the contemporary scene and that's
invalid the kgb
was was absolutely brutal in
interrogating people
shooting them in the back of the head
and using
all kinds of brutality which
unimaginable
is very similar to what the nazis did
this is one of the torture methods you
put a board or
something to prevent real injuries
bruises and stuff
like that but to the head
last time did you give a boucher to the
americans
means are much more subtle and much more
psychological than this kind of stuff
you you threaten somebody with a gun
if they get out of it they will hate you
forever there's a
number of ways to make somebody switch
uh
a threat to to your family
that's a very very strong incentive
when you have somebody who is like i i
lived in the united states for for 10
years and i had
gotten used to some a significant
improved lifestyle
i had become an american in many
respects no i i think sexpionage
that's reality i'd be surprised if if
there are any major intelligence
services
that aren't in some way recruiting women
to do dirty work uh i would not
recommend this
then the message comes through
we read you
this thing starts typing and then and
the fellow happens to be
in the place where it starts typing well
how do we know that he's there
there is no real way for somebody who
was
truly in isolation to give somebody an
urgent message
the fastest way for me to receive and
have received an urgent message in those
days
was through signals and that would be
with possible delay of about a day or
at least to half a day let's say in the
evening the agent sets the signal
in the morning i read it is it possible
to
intercept a teletype message i don't
know because i think in those days you
know through
radio transmissions would would have
been preferable and they wouldn't just
come on
spontaneously i mean if you want to hand
over
documentation about uh say a weapon
system
you know what how do you do this the
easiest way is to if you can you steal
it and put it on a
electronic media but if it's just a real
short message such as get out of here a
phone call but you have to be
now aware that phone calls are traced
there's also communication that
messages are compressed and
transmitted in in bursts and short
bursts
and then they get decompressed at the
other end but again that has to be
scheduled
number stations when if you go and into
a short
in a radio receiver and you you go
and scan short waves you will
occasionally hear something when
somebody says
five eight six nine
that's the secret message for somebody
to be decoded
i looked for her everywhere i couldn't
find her at the airport and even
look through all the flight lists
i headed down to the harbour
in this business if you have an asset
and we're talking about acid it's a
human being who
is working with you you want to do
everything to protect them
you know we're talking uh you know an
agent who
who who is trying to protect a a russian
who is working with him
i think that's entirely realistic
hey jim me and eileen uh been figuring
you could use a little entertainment yes
all right thank you that would be lovely
well the uh purported agent is way too
good looking
we think that uh brosnan is is actually
a russian
he has no accent there is no such thing
as a russian
born in russia raised in russia
can speak english with without an accent
god damn
you're pretty good jimmy yeah too damn
good
you'll be yourself you know if you're
good at something you know you show off
you play along that was the whole idea
you you you want to befriend a lot of
people and you just want to blend in
the best you can you don't want to stand
out too much you know i made a big
mistake i
i went back to college in the us
and i aced the entire program
but you know showing off bowling skills
why not you know
if you're a good golfer somebody may
want to play golf with you and that's
how you get to know people that might be
of interest
this was very entertaining i mean i
laughed
particularly at the sentence we use live
targets